hello ladies gentlemen I'm Ryan Wright
and I'm Andrew so today Andrew and I are
gonna check out from all-time movies the
top 5 worst movie reboots their special
little list
Andrew now we're talking before this
guessing what could be under you were
saying Nightmare on Elm Street yeah that
move was awful my personally hated Total
Recall I stopped that movie halfway
through and the only way I'm gonna
continue this is born of Schwarzenegger
comes in hi I'm Chris now son remakes
are just awesome I was committed in the
original impact but we're not going to
talk about those oh no these are the top
5 worst movie reboots ever number 5
Planet of the Apes pretty bad although
at times humorously outdated perhaps
best known for its a twist ending he was
trying to outdo the 1968 ending and come
up with the twist even more shocking the
result instead this all happen stupid
rating it's basically just a bad chase
film with monkey puppets this bunch is
just to makeup effects for grantham stay
away from remakes Tim and then I read no
really get them away from that remakes
in number four the amazing spider-man is
too soon for a complete series reboot
Sony didn't think that and Peter Parker
returned to the amazing spider-man
spider-man the circle of the origin
story told in 2002 spider-man tip this
time with the lizard instead of the
Green Goblin
pretty familiar just you know more
cheesy and a lot more Hollywood I
thought of all the references they
managed to hire actors playing high
school students that looked even older
now amazing spider-man 2 was a
box-office flop but never fear Spidey
fans yet another spider-man is said to
appear in the next Avengers Bowl
I know I can't wait number three they're
eagerly favorable the original came out
in 1984 and was so popular but six
sequels came out by 1994 but there was
also a TV series oh I didn't know that I
know right so a lot of teenagers for a
very long time but with no input from
crates of West Craven didn't go see it
and had nothing to do with it it's less
surprising that 2010 reboot was a flop
starring really Mara and a blonde woman
who looks 35 looks like they were
supported from The Shining number two
then a radio show in the 50s TV series
in the 60s and a series of films happen
till the mid-2000s catch me when the
guys who did Pirates of the Caribbean
decided to take on the Lone Ranger bases
pretty outdated story they brought up to
a tricky start by casting Johnny Depp as
Native American sidekick Tonto if
although Johnny Depp insists and I quote
my great-grandmother was quite a bit of
Native American good to know Johnny
accusations of casual racism aside
reviewers and audiences alike felt that
the film is far too long too boring and
way too hokey
yeah just stick to the swashbuckling
pirates guys would be worse do be worse
how could this be what number one
Pink Panther 2006 Thank You Bamberger
wonderful some of my favorites and Steve
Martin just can't live up to it why on
earth would you try to go
to take the comedic genius of the great
Peter Sellers you can't jokes that fresh
if you have one for me yes Tammy and
really forced from Magan I would like to
buy the reboots of Pink Panther did well
enough at the box office to warrant a
sequel a snowman party was a big enough
but to kill the second coming of you so
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to click here to see the top 5 worst sex
scenes in movies I promise you Wow
ok so first one was number five was
Planet of the Apes really there are
things about it that I do appreciate
intent like what he sought out to
because he wasn't said it's clear that
he's not setting out to make a bad movie
there was a lot of work put into it I
remember when the DVD came out there was
over 50 hours of behind-the-scenes
footage they put a lot of work into it
it just didn't turn out well man
absolutely and I completely agree with
what you said earlier the makeup in that
film was fantastic but totally that
ending was just you and I was like 12 or
13 the theater and I saw like what the
heck that's right that's completely
ridiculous you know when you see the
first point I remember I saw the first
plan of the Apes right before watching
the reboot I was really young and I'm
watching ending going yo todd chill the
[ __ ] out pussycat
I remember watching that ending and
being like holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] insane and you get chills
when I saw the remake everyone started
cracking up that it was just a theater
full of hysterical people madness oh
yeah that was a pretty disappointed
Marvel
it's not that great yeah no that was
before he got good yeah there's a period
where Mark Wahlberg wasn't that grabbed
salute he did like Boogie Nights and a
bunch of mainstream movies that weren't
that great and then he got really good
and everyone always has one bad day at
the office sometimes too you know
someone have so it happens you know he
got better and it is what it is but but
I agree with you I thought the intent
was very good you know I watched a lot
of that behind the scenes - they
definitely worked hard in the film just
was a complete mess yeah unfortunately
and there number four was the amazing
spider-man okay amazing spider-man - I
was let down by this big time I think if
you watch my review for it I was like
yeah but the first one I remember really
enjoying it I'm like sure it's another
origin tale but if you get past the fact
that it's another origin tale and you
witness and feel the differences it
makes it worthwhile I'm not like in love
with it I think it's a good film you
know I definitely see where the guy why
I understood why you put on as a list
but I just I don't agree with so but
that list is the worst yeah movie read
that to me movie was not I've seen way
worse reboots than that film that film
was not again I felt some similarities I
know you say you don't feel the
similarities but definitely you know
because it was so close I guess is why I
felt some of the origin but again there
was a lot of different stuff around it
they hiked gwen stacy obviously not mary
jane and this i thought the love
connection was much better yeah i like
that they were more in high school now
that the other one just kind of got to
college and I'd say late to the round
the 30 minute or you watch the first
spider-man it feels kind of cartoony a
little comic book II that one felt like
yeah this is a more serious more serious
darker take on it and are tonight taken
yeah exactly what everyone started doing
for a while and then you have Andrew
Garfield here's a totally different type
of Peter Parker and I like his
interpretation too like I'm like yeah
he's more wisecracking and stuff I'm
like that's more like the Peter Parker I
know so to have like a wisecrack is sure
he's like a good looking dude but so
yeah oh yeah yeah absolutely so I think
that guy should have put four top five
worst sequels definitely amazing
spider-man 2 should be in there for top
five worst reboots I don't know if I
agree with the amazing spider-man and
The Nightmare on Elm Street was a number
three choice that is a I mean I didn't
finish that one either I
I I got your you're the lucky one huh I
finished it you finished it
unfortunately yeah I just couldn't sit
through it I was like really bored oh I
was - that's the thing they were missing
so much about Freddy Krueger was [ __ ]
personality you know like there's no
personality all those actors named uh
Jackie Earle Haley yes Lynette was the
new one the original was Robert Englund
who was fantastic so good
I remember when Jackie Earle Haley got
the role people were actually like
alright he just did Watchmen and he
stole the show he wasn't I remember it
watch mandolin when he said what is the
famous line that he said you're the
world when he's in the prison he's like
oh I'm not in here with you you're in me
everyone startled yeah so I was like
okay I could get on board
it was so boring yeah and Rooney Mara
even said I didn't want to do it but I
just did it
well yeah I mean a couple things that
they should have understood if you
re-watch the first film you don't even
see Freddy in it that much right now you
know it's just it's the thought of him
like he can kill you on your drink you
didn't need to see it just the sequels
and where he started coming camp yeah
you know and I understood why they were
trying to do they were trying to you
know make you know maximize their
product I get that you know purpose of
it so but the new one they should have
went back to what me well made the
franchise great in the first place I'm
not saying you know put less Freddy in
but you know definitely a little less
Freddy in me and stop with the jump
scares every two minutes and it's you
know what I mean it doesn't make your
story better
and then when they pay homage you're
like I'd rather just be watching the
original right I'm like and also to one
other thing they didn't bad in that film
if you watch the reason the first one
you're with Nancy just about the whole
film and not that you're not with
Nancy's film it's like Katie Cassidy is
kind of the the lead a little bit the
Latina character that she's read they're
redoing and then halfway through now
it's Nancy after she's been killed and
in the first one it was basically you
were with Nancy the whole way through
the film and she was the hero and she
was smart and she's like though and how
she went a home alone on Freddie at the
end loved him this man I just didn't I
didn't care if he died and I didn't care
the Lone Ranger was one of those films
that I saw after everyone was hating on
it and I was like alright here we go
another movie Johnny Depp was like the
most amazing
after to me for a long time and then he
started really letting me down and then
Lone Ranger just added to that yeah I
saw the move do you see it
I actually a funny story I saw the last
Johnny Depp Gore Verbinski film I saw
was Pirates of the Caribbean at World's
End and after I saw them and after I
heard the stuff that was the reviews and
everyone what they were saying I was
like nope not gonna watch it so Pirates
of the Caribbean 3 was one of the worst
movies I've ever had I hate that movie I
despised it and then when I read there
and read and heard the reviews and
everyone told me how awful this phone
was like No so I stayed away but
honestly I have a few good laughs when I
was watching the loan rate you know
Tarantino well I think the year was 2013
it came out yeah and Tarantino put it on
his list of one of his favorite movies
that year well you know and like I've
said before all films are subjective no
no one is actually right or wrong you
know and the Pink Panther to me the
first one because I was like what's the
point of this guy trying to do the pink
like at least do it differently instead
of doing a mock performance and pull in
person yeah but I ended up like kind of
enjoying the first one second one though
I I really did it was actually kind of a
racist and sexist film - anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can follow andrew
on twitter he tweets a lot a lot more
than we tweet twitter.com slash egg or
7-eleven
you should see a title text here for how
it's spelled right there
man juice crotch and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope you have a periscope yet I
don't I'm not cool I guess like everyone
else the rest nervous I'm definitely
cool i periscope like once every two
months
but I get followers because I keep
telling people follow me it's the way I